hearthstone is a game of wits you create
a deck from hundreds of cards and battle
it out against the collective hive mind
of the internet and usually you lose or
at least that's been my experience with
the game but I've been well and truly
caught up in the hearthstone bubble
because pretty much everyone in the game
spot UK office plays like Rob here hello
thanks to him I know what the meta is
which is basically a word for how most
people are playing the game and what
strategies they're using in hearthstone
it's where players use various popular
decks characters or strategies to get
the highest possible win rate the meta
is ever-evolving but in recent months
people have been relying on the same old
tactics that is a deck made up of 30
super cheap and super aggressive cards
known as an aggro or a face deck so a
game of endless possibility is reduced
down to one where people are just using
the same old net decks that they've
found on reddit so Rob is going to
change anytime soon its expansion time
as part of the game's latest expansion
the grand tournament which is due to
release this month Blizzard has
introduced a new gameplay mechanic the
joust well what's a tournament without a
jouster exactly the premise is simple
you play a minion with a joust battle
cry and then both you and your opponent
will pull a random card from your deck
show it and then shuffle it back in if
you're revealed card was shown to be
more expensive than theirs then the
minion you dropped will be given a nice
bonus if your card isn't more expensive
than you ain't take a look at this new
meaning for instance the gadget zan
ghoul stir it costs one manner and has
its baseline stats on one attack and to
health that's nothing to write home
about however this little fellow will
activate a joust as soon as he hits the
board and if you wins it becomes a one
manner 23 which to be frank is pretty
deadly it's basically a zombie Chow
without the restore 5 health penalty
there's some awesome hero cards with
gels two shamans healing way for example
restores seven health for free manner
which is a pretty
good deal however also activates joust
and if one shaman gets 14 health which
is genuinely genuinely insane and here's
the thing the reason why this new
mechanic has got people talking is
because aggro decks which let's not
forget having running roughshod over the
metaphor nearly a year now are
particularly vulnerable to joust why
well because nearly every card in an
aggro deck is valued at about 3 manner
or less there's that popular little one
mana jerk the abusive sergeant and that
devastating 3 manner arcane golem and
who can forget that total [ __ ] knife
juggler and his stupid haunted creeper
buddies as incredibly frustrating as it
can sometimes be to see these monsters
across the board douse ting an aggro
deck is going to be way more successful
than against pretty much any other deck
and so with the joust mechanic added to
the upcoming expansion the curse of
aggro decks may finally be over or at
least there's now a [ __ ] in its am so
what you're saying is that just might
save half stone from a grow or my not
yeah it kind of depends what Trump says
the guy with the hair no he's he's
running for president really hearthstone
is big we'll see you next week
that is making a deck of soup I'm
actually do it's good yeah you have to
flem up sometimes your sufferings will
show plus some hearthstone angle haha
are so so it's real good